for centuries my ancestors have been the
callers of powerful elements rain the
fog the wind and the storms of our land
they did this through hula and through a
very strong belief system that when we
call they'll come
waimea is like no other town in the
state of Hawaii we don't have any
coconut trees in town we're the closest
town to Mauna Kea and so we get a lot of
rain that settles here we truly are the
people of the clouds our children are
named after the fog our children are
named after the ring we are the halal
for Waimea we are known to be able to
call the elements where needed rain fog
when the storms of our land and so our
dancers mimic the whipping of the wind
and the pounding of the rain on the
outside it looks like it's just
entertainment we are not a halau that
entertains you won't see us down at the
hotel's you are watching the physical
manifestation of the spiritual world
that we inhabit
we are completely woven into our
community when there's not enough snow
on the mountain we get calls from
astronomers to help call the snow
in times of drought were often called to
chant into the heavens and ask the ring
to feed and nourish the land you know
every time we call them they come but
they don't just come because you call
them your inside has to really pull them
when you're finished with all of your
chance
you should be drenched in sweat it makes
it so much more powerful to be wearing
what your ancestors wore they wore what
we call Coppa it comes from a plant that
we call welke it's gathered the bark is
stripped off it's soaked and then
pounded you go through weeks and even
months of pounding and pounding you want
the fabric to come out like soft cotton
and when we're all pounding copper you
can hear it about two miles down the
road transport them into the realm of
what our ancestors have to do to be in a
hollow you need to go through the entire
process of the copper without your skirt
you can't dance
[Music]
it's the pinnacle of the hula dancers
career to be able to dance in the forest
amongst the most supreme beans
[Music]
we'll hike into the back of the forest
or on the top of the mountain and no
one's there just us and we dance for the
only audience that matters which is our
ancestors they're in the form of the
plants that are around us the hills that
surround us
the wind and the rain that comes and
caresses us after we have danced
we'd only remember what happened we just
remember that we're in complete bliss
you
[Music]